well thank you thank you uh joyce
for such such amazing talks to start
this off and
thank you shafi and the simons institute
for for hosting this
and um yeah really healing hearing from
the gamut of elephants to plants and
i think you're you're really going to do
a job to the vegetarian movement
here which i hope you should be prepared
for you know now there's really nothing
left to eat
um if plants have the consciousness that
you're
you're saying but which actually brings
me to
to this project on sperm whales um as we
were mentioning earlier um
shafi michael and i met at radcliffe and
i and i came to radcliffe as uh
i was studying jellyfish um there's even
a rad clip there's an article in the
harvard gazette called the jellyfish guy
and i was trying to find ways to really
show people how interesting jellyfish
are and how they could permeate people's
hearts
and i couldn't get anybody interested
not even the radcliffe fellows
and um it was really great when when i
came across shane's
shane giro's research on on sperm whales
i mean these are
you know the charismatic megafauna the
essentially moby dick and um and when
shafi kind of uh
called attention to their to their
sounds and to the potential of machine
learning
it it got the wheels turning and and
really is the
the glue that brought this group
together so
it's it's uh it's a great honor to to
introduce uh shane giro who runs the
dominican sperm whale project
um as well as uh pratyusha sharma
who's at mit c sail and is in the
the research group of uh daniella roos
and is also working with
jacob andreas and antonio tarabla who
are
heavily involved in this project so this
essentially
is a shane pled to the seat for this 15
years ago
and we're now beginning to apply some of
these
advanced machine learning tools so um
shane and patricia why don't you
you take it away and thank you
hi everybody let me uh
is everybody able to see my title slide
yeah great um
okay
all right
so hi um my name is shane garrow and uh
i'm the biology lead for project seti
and i'm affiliated with the marine
bioacoustics lab at oaklands university
in denmark
and the biology department at the
dalhousie university here in canada
and as david said i'm the founder of the
dominican firmware project
so before we dive into uh sperm whale
communication i just wanted to take a
quick
step backwards language is really being
sort of a unifying and divisive force
among human populations and in our human
case
language has helped us to solve a really
important problem of with whom to spend
time and who to cooperate with
by identifying sort of other strangers
that share similar social norms of
behaviors to us
and that's helped lead the way to the
evolution of cultural groups and a
cultural identity
but on the other hand you know wars are
often fought over differences as simple
as language
and the differences that they label that
exist between groups
so over the course of history these
divisions have been really important
in terms of structuring and the
geographic spread and the success of
different human
societies and i think this plot of the
23 most commonly spoken languages
around the world really highlights the
divisions that language can have
now there's a growing body of work that
demonstrates that humans are not the
only cultural species and that animal
cultural traditions pervade
most parts of their lives in this
enormous
study several primatologists summarize
the diversity and density
of the richness of chimpanzee culture
across africa
so animals and maybe plants uh including
bees birds and primates
they can learn from each other and pass
on acquired knowledge and in some cases
that's really closely linked with their
social identity
so when we talk about decoding the
communication of
non-human species it's more than
questions about
what they're saying to each other and
what the properties of those sounds are
and what the structure and rules that
govern how they do that
it's really about who they are and why
they live together
and it's about solutions to living
together for coexistence
and ultimately the evolution of
complicated societies
and oceanic societies look really
different but provide us with some
advantages when we study them
i think the most overlooked reality when
we're looking in the ocean as opposed to
on land
the ocean is really big and deep and
dark
and wet and as a result of living in
these giant spaces
many whales and dolphins operate over
relatively larger spatial
and temporal scales compared to primates
or even elephants
and many cover thousands of kilometers
and some are thought to live over 100
years old
and there's very little evidence of
territoriality
there's no fighting for a place
so compared to terrestrial species
marine species also experience
substantially greater environmental
variation over periods of months
and longer so once you sort of take out
the predictabilities of daily and
seasonal cycles
the noise in a terrestrial environment
is very white as well as in the oceanic
environment it tends to be very red
or and this means that the ocean
uh over longer time scales creates a
situation where you want to learn from
each other
rather than learning on your own or
having behavior be
genetically determined and if you take
that with the fact that a lot of whales
and dolphins live in long-term stable
families
with prolonged parental care there's a
lot of opportunity to learn from each
other
and so we see a lot of culturally
transmitted behavior
and as a result there's several species
that we see that have lots of
differences between social groups
and that we think is due to learning
from each other
now sperm whales have been sperm whales
for longer than
humanity has walked up so they have
these really rich
socialized and complex communication
systems that have arisen
and so therefore uh along with the
points above about the ocean itself the
citations are really
important tax on for asking questions
about the sort of nexus of interaction
between communication
uh you know social structure and culture
in particular given they have
cognitive abilities um and societies
that
rival the animals that we study on land
but importantly they also give us a
really interesting
dramatic contrast in ecology you know
sperm whales are the largest
of all of the tooth whales they have the
world's largest brain
physically speaking uh they can be found
worldwide and share many
like traits with the elephants that
joyce has so nicely summarized and he'll
already talk
and so over the last 15 years i've been
focused on a long term study of sperm
whales
i've been following the lives of sperm
whale families off the coast of dominica
since 2005
through thousands of hours of
observation now it's really being the
first time that anyone's really come to
know these animals
as individuals with brothers and sisters
and mothers and babysitters
and as families and neighbors our
population estimate maxes out around 400
individuals
which broken down into about 30
different families of which of
16 we know quite well and have fallen
across years
now compared to other sites where sperm
also have been studied
these units show really high residency
times they're
spending a lot of time off the coast of
dominica and in the eastern caribbean
and that's a huge advantage when you're
studying communication
we can reliably see the same animals
across days and weeks and months
and through years and we can study them
as they age
as they become moms and across different
behavioral contexts
in truth really there's been no other
population of sperm whales that is being
this well characterized for most
individuals we know their reproductive
history
their family relationships their habitat
use around dominica
and the wider islands their place in
social network
and individual android specific
localizations
and even their little behavioral
idiosyncrasies
so this really allows us to ask a lot
deeper questions
about what it means
and so when a sperm whale makes these
deep dives for squid she's among the
deepest and longest divers
you can hold breath for over an hour and
make dives three times deeper than most
modern nuclear attacks spend 80 percent
of her life in the darkness of the
devotion and only about 10 to 15 minutes
of every hour
in the part of the ocean that light
touches so as a result the world
is dominated by sound and so just like
that's
something else involved the system of
echolocation you'll see
and there you know uh houses the world's
uh
the largest natural sonar system and
that's allowed them to exploit the deep
parts of the ocean
that we find even harder to get to and
as a result spur whales are significant
part of the ocean ecosystem
some whales eat as much squid as all of
human fisheries can buy
and we're going to make these amazing
clips by moving air around their
high-level
heads and in addition to a bunch of
other rare balls they create
two distinct types which we believe
circulated different colors the other
location clips here
in excess of 200 decibels and bird well
over 10
kilometers away and most of the
activation energy
travels to the head of the whale on the
crust once you just put here
on the top and then uh on the bottom
uh and that is clear broadband pulse
that's
disturbance i don't know if other people
are hearing it
oh no i think it's coming from your
connection are you are you
wi-fi no i'm
i'm on a fixed line is it breaking up or
is it noisy
it sounds like there's another noise
underneath you so you're over
talking over something you only have one
connection open
you have an external microphone that
you're using
uh nope it's built into my surface
it's good now yeah it actually sounds
better now
yeah now it sounds not can i not be
understood at all or
no just the last second or two oh okay
now it's good maybe we continue okay
yeah
repeat the last phrase sure and just
someone put up their hand if it comes
back
um right but they the second type of
click that they make
is called a code a click and they
exchange these quotas
uh in doubts when two or more animals
are together
uh either when they're diving together
or when they're socializing at the
surface
and that's we never made it
dakota clicks the one on the bottom here
uh have a more obvious
um multi-pulsed structure and that's
because the sound actually reflects in
multiple products
and it doesn't go down
and
i'm not sure why that would be
i noticed that uh whenever one of you
try to talk
i get the livestream
so we are
and now is it better now that everybody
is muted
as two different clip types um
but both share a unique property false
control
which is a byproduct of the size of this
and that allows us to describe be able
to
measure the way all that producing and
that sort of lies
grandmothers mothers
and they immediately raise and defend
their family
and it turns out survival
and the sperm whale families they could
be are very small
at seven whales and they tend to be
encountered alone offshore
on any given day you're getting only 50
whales
and that's really being the key in our
ability to develop
an understanding of their social lives
um
building a family album through photo
identification of these animals
can also show preferences to other
families
uh and pairs of families that have been
uh
together across decades that we call a
bond group
uh which is following from the
terminology of elephants into a single
pattern
um but each family has their own way of
doing things and they live
in a community of neighboring families
uh of which this is a small subset so
fnu are a bond pair
these are two more bonded uh pairs of
families and this is the sunset uh of
the social network
off the coast of dominica
and they seem to mediate these social
relationships with distinct and
clicks uh with stereotypic rhythm and
tempo that we call
codas and there are two main categories
of codas there are regular codas
where the timing between the clicks are
all the same like this five artwork
and then there are irregular quotas
where the inter-click
intervals or the ici uh is different
like this one
plus one plus
so in the first few hundred meters as
they dive together they make codas in
sort of duet like sequences before
starting their echolocation and
splitting up the unprecedented
death and these conversations offering
often include
overlapping halls and matching of
prototypes or coat of patterns
i like to say that there's this elegant
complexity to what is apparently a
simple
uh system of their exchange but more
often than not
the changes are far more complex quota
bouts can last
more than half an hour and social
periods but are all playing together
the surface and making codes from last
hours and are filled with filters
so this is an exchange between one of
the well-known
units of whales we call them a group of
seven probably the best studied
unit of whales anywhere in the world and
we spent hundreds of hours just with
these animals
and it gives you an idea of the
complexity of the exchange and maybe
also an ear for the different
photographs
and our produce research has shown that
the whales exhibit
patterns of quotas that allow us to
discriminate individuals
uh family units and what we call clans
in these what seem to be nested levels
of identity
but the level of the individual we found
a really variable 5r1
so 5 regularly spaced clicks or close to
it
that allowed us to reliably discriminate
individual unit measures
this is really interesting because it's
one of the few prototypes that we hear
all around the world
and this sort of fits our cultural
interpretation because you would expect
that
any population of its females regardless
of where they live
would need to interact at the individual
level um
it's also interesting because these five
r1 codas
often start sequences of photos so they
the first
uh calls they make before continuing to
speak and particularly when they're
starting
dives before they separate so socially
isolate when they go to death
to hunt among units in the caribbean
there are characteristic uh
four click quotas so codas with four
different clicks
and we think these serve to mediate
recognition at greater distances when
they're deciding whether or not
to meet up and in particular it would
allow for the identification of bond
group pairs
after long separations as bond groups
have
relationships that last decades across
long term multi-year separations
and we've def we've demonstrated that
there are socially segregated
sympathetic plans uh in the caribbean
with
significantly distinct dialects so units
in the eastern caribbean plan here in
green
produce the one plus one have plus three
coda
and and the ec2 clan which is red
never produces that coda but instead
produces a really long
five regular code what's interesting is
this one plus one plus three is unique
to the caribbean whales
it's only ever been heard in the
caribbean and it's been identical for at
least the last 30 years
uh have spent about two years learning
to make it correctly they'll actually
babble
um and produce a higher diversity of
calls
prior to sort of narrowing down their
dialect
to be more like their families uh but
they do learn it
accurately and we think that this is to
ensure that the clan
can be recognized across huge geographic
ranges that they use
so if you think about it these are
calves that live in families
that spend very little time together
spread across hundreds of kilometers and
yet they're able to learn
this particular call in a very
stereotypical way
and they have to because we think that
when two sperm royal families meet at
sea
they need to recognize whether or not
you belong to my clan
because it turns out that sperm whale
families in the same clan will spend
time together
while families that speak different
dialects from different clans
won't spend any time but for
any vocal uh recognition system to work
it needs three different things
it needs signals that vary or are
stereotyped
to provide that you need receivers that
can distinguish those signals
and then you need receivers that respond
differently
um now the patterns that we've just
talked about
uh show evidence of number one right
that there are different uh types of
signals
and and the social structure that we see
shows that they must respond differently
to their con specific identities which
is
evidence of number three but one of the
big outstanding questions is do they
recognize
cultural identity and to address this we
conduct playback experiments
really the only way of asking the whales
what they think
and these are you know controlled
playbacks where we play
one from their family one from a
different family and a control
which is a distance firmware
electrolocation
and we enlisted uh two behavioral
responses in our first
seven preliminary trials and in one case
we played a one plus one plus three coda
to a family from the other clan and they
almost immediately stopped feeding
which they had been doing for the last
seven hours uh and they all
surfaced and started to socialize for
several hours
uh through the remaining uh playback
sequence and actually until we were
forced to leave them that night because
of rough weather
in the other case which was particularly
interesting we played the same clan
coda we played a one plus one plus three
product and
to um a focal female in unit f
which is the group of seven that you
guys previously met earlier in the talk
uh and she responded with a series of
four d codas
which we've shown is actually the unit
level uh
discriminator for this particular family
and the female didn't respond to the
control or the other
test program so in all cases however we
did find that the
animals would inspect the vessel and
make close approaches after
uh we did a playback which suggests that
there's generally a response
uh to our codas and potentially that
they're able to recognize voice cues of
the animal that
actually created that call so clearly
this is preliminary work
uh it's a small step that can be
extended
as a foundation of a continued playback
experiment
but uh the vocal response of a unit
specific coda after we play plan
specific one is really interesting
in terms of our social identity
hypothesis so clearly
it's the basis for continued work
importantly there's only two
uh these are only two key characteristic
codas uh that allow us to distinguish
the clans but the whales and eastern
province make
24 different photo patterns and they
concatenate them into long
sequences so
their communication really system really
provides us
two different benefits when trying to
decode it one is that on its face
it's quite simple it's a series of
clicks it's almost binary in that there
are clicks
intervals uh but there's also complexity
in the way that these codas are
sequenced
and exchanged uh which vary both within
and between individuals
or across behavioral context so we've
really only begun to include things like
spectral characteristics
and that means there's far more depths
uh and structures for us to look at
and certainly far more than we
understand right now
um and i just wanted to show you what is
a bit of a complex figure but what we're
doing now is delineating clans across
both the pacific and atlantic ocean
so the top dendrogram here is the
clustering of similar
uh repertoires among different families
and the colors show the clans that come
out of it
and the darkened boxes below denote the
characteristic
identity codas that allow us to
discriminate them so these identity
coders have been classified using
contaminated mixture models and then
discriminated from all other codas
based on the presence of of it being
used by a given clade but not by any
other
and that they're distinct in terms of
their patterning in the multivariate
quick interval space so there are clear
divisions that come out
uh from the five tropical pacific clans
and the six north atlantic lands
uh and this is the progress in another
project i'm leaving called the
global coda dialect project where we
have data sets
from all over the world and we're
looking at estimating a number of clans
worldwide
so that that can serve as the foundation
for restructuring large-scale
conservation policies
but also in search of global universal
quotas in addition to these really
distinct
identity codes so one could think that
these divisions that we're seeing here
in the acoustics
is maybe data logical or random if we're
not grounding them in some kind of
contextual data
um and in truth plans were discovered
simply as variation in coda patterns
um but we've now grounded these acoustic
divisions
with social movement diet and behavioral
data showing that these clans
live syntactically in the same water uh
but are socially
segregated uh and that they differ in a
number of behaviors across
contexts and so that means we can build
a much more clear
picture about the potential function of
their codas as markers of social
identity
so behavior is really what you're doing
with culture is how you learn to do it
and all sperm whales seem to do the same
thing they hunt they eat they forage but
they all do it differently
and just as some humans will eat the
forks this evening and others will use
chopsticks these whale clans different
what they eat
how they eat how fast they travel where
they roam
they differ in their social behaviors
and probably in a number of ways we
don't understand
novel technology
at all not now it's just some a little
too noisy
um maybe try again or maybe we need to
disconnect and reconnect but try again
yeah i think it was the video um
let's see if it'll work this time
no it seems like when you run your video
it it also
interferes with your voice and it makes
the video choppy it looks like
okay so maybe it is the bandwidth on on
my end
um are you able to see me hear me now on
a static picture
yes okay great um i'm sorry i don't know
what's going on
um all that to say is that we have these
new pieces of technology that we've been
deploying on the backs of the animals
that allow us
to relate um uh
their acoustic behavior along with all
of the behavior of their movement
uh and depth and pressure and light uh
and so on and that has been really
revealing in our ability to link
uh the sounds they're making to the
context in which they're being used
um and a few years ago but what but what
that has done
in effect has uh enabled us to collect
larger
longer recordings uh but it hasn't
accelerated our ability to process
uh or annotate uh or extract any of the
the codas from those longer recordings
and that's one of the things that has
really pushed us towards
uh project seti and a few years ago
michael david rob wood and i along with
a very
very hard-working student named peter
berman conducted sort of a proof of
concept study to demonstrate that neural
networks should produce
meaningful classifications and photos as
well as the prediction
of social identity both for individuals
and clients
but i'll let patricia talk about that
next
so this work has really laid the
foundation for what we're going to
undertake with project city
and i hope it's clear that these whales
and the way that we've approached
studying them
has produced a platform for making big
steps forward in our understanding of
sperm welcome
these animals are very different but in
fundamental ways they're very similar to
us and if we can find deep similarities
between their lives and our lives then
how different are we all really so in
the middle of a pandemic
and with the climate crisis looming it
can be easy
to think that this is an overly academic
thing to talk about whale culture
and decoding non-humans but the
take-home message from these whale
stories uh
after listening to them for over a
decade is that we have to go out and
build
bigger definitions of us so at a time in
history
uh when humans are really at their most
divided uh if we're going to make a
change here and preserve life we need to
find empathy for our neighbors
and find ways to coexist and i think
that will be the larger legacy
to study thank you
okay thank you shane uh partucia you
want to
take it from here uh yes thank thanks
david uh
i just have one question so how much
time do we have of studying now
uh you have a half hour okay um
okay oh shane i cannot share my screen
oh
i'm just trying to turn that off right
now okay
not letting me see anything except for
all of your lovely faces
all right
okay
um so good morning everyone
i'm producia and i'm a phd student at
school
you're in uh presenter mode you're we're
seeing your presenter mode can you
sorry
okay is this better
uh no we're not saying your screen oh
okay
there we go yeah good okay um
so well good morning everyone i'm
pratyusha and i'm
a phd student at ccsa at mit and today
i'll be talking about our first steps
towards understanding spill mail
communication
so uh this work is done jointly together
with my advisor professor antonio
turalba
professor jacob andreas professor
daniela roos at mit
and with the rest of the wonderful saudi
team
so uh this will be the flow of the talk
sorry
oh okay now i see the screen i didn't
see it a minute ago okay
okay okay so this is going to be the
flow of the talk with uh briefly
first talk about the motivation behind
this project and then we'll talk about
the progress we've made so far
okay so the first question that we want
to look at is why
why should we study whales so uh shane
has already convinced us of how
beautiful and amazing
uh sperm wheels are and he's it's
already
uh he's already amazed us with all the
wonderful
capabilities that they have developed
over
millions of years and just adding to
that we
also have the largest brains in the
world besides that they have
really sophisticated communication
systems across large distances
and they have very rich cultures and
adding to that there's also that uh
underwater since there's complete
darkness
sound is a major mode of sensing not
just to communicate but also to
visualize or like via ecolocation
the second important question that we
try to answer is why
study communication so communication is
a major
sign of intelligence and it tells us
about the ability of an organism
to compose and structure very complex
responses
to really study communication or to
discover the presence or absence of
language
you want to be looking at these five
things the first thing is discreteness
which is the presence of units the
second thing is grammar
which is uh the the rules or the uh
the the rules that apply over these
discrete units to
generate sentences the third one is uh
the presence of long-range dependencies
such that uh how far behind in the
context
do the sperm where three rely on to
generate the next sentence
the third one is productivity which is
the ability to create infinite number of
messages
given the first and the second uh given
the sweetness and grammar
and finally displacement which is the
ability to talk about things that aren't
directly in front of you uh
finally no other animal so far has been
proven to have the gift of language
or show all of these five different
things so
our quest really is to see if there are
these five different things
present in spermal communication so now
let's look at uh
what these sounds sound like uh
is it audible okay so
uh on the left side is the audio playing
and while on the right side
is the wave plot of the corresponding
audio so sperm wheels make
sounds or they make click sounds to both
communicate and equal locate
but as shane previously talked about the
distinctions between the two equal
communication clicks are more tightly
packed such as in one second here we can
see five different communications
the next thing that shane also mentioned
was
about the ici and ipi and these are
terms we'll use in the rest of the
presentation so
just a quick intro so ici is given a
coder the distance between consecutive
clicks
and ipi is if you pick one of these
clicks and zoom in
really you see these different boxes and
ipi is the distance between
the peaks of two consecutive pulses
okay now coming to the data that we have
so
collecting data with sperm waves is
extremely
difficult and the data is very very
precious
and the two kinds of data one that can
be collected by
uh hanging a microphone uh a hydrophone
down the boat
and another is this way by tagging waves
using d tags
and shane and his team has collected
this really rich data set
containing about 4 000 different coders
containing a total of
roughly 22 000 clicks and these are
stereo audio recordings
and after that they've also had
annotated them with rich annotations of
icis and ipis
and in addition to all this is also
other metadata
mentioned on the slide
and besides this data there's also
additional audio data
but there is no annotations for this
audio data
uh now here just do a quick review of
the previous work which is done
on this data so one thing is to look at
whether the presence or absence of click
this is done by uh
at all and they look at the presence or
absence of click in a given
uh image or a spectrogram of the wave
and or the way they get
you get ground truth for this is uh in
the paper is
we are thresholding the signal
and next they also look at clustering
coders across clans and individuals
and find these beautiful patterns and
these are
the different codas seem to be separate
uh separable across these different
groups
finally they also look at uh
classification experiments where they do
code type classification
vocal clan classification across two
clans and also individual veil
identification across two whales
so they i think these are very very
interesting experiments
and it's it's a really uh good uh it's a
really good start to
assume that clicks can be thought of as
binary clean signals
as a click or a no click and uh
also these experiments can then be used
to further generate
labels for the rest of the data set of
about
coda type classification vocal
classification and veil identification
but if you look at what is missing the
same advantage can also turn out to be a
little bit of a disadvantage
while treating them as binary signals is
a good good start
there could be other features that we
could be missing out on such as power
for example
the way we emphasize on different words
could mean different things
and can convey emotions which could
completely mean different things
finally uh and another thing is there's
also simplifying assumptions that could
be
that are made about the prototypes and
variations and the
third thing is generalization beyond
heuristics
so uh generalization beyond heuristics i
by that i mean that uh like for the
click detector
uh there's oh there's an assumption that
beyond this threshold
would be a click and this is that would
not be a click
but actually in reality when we look at
data there's a lot of soft clicks
which when we uh reuse uh retrain a
model using the same approach
uh the performance drops from almost 99
to 7 on the softer clicks so
what we really want to do is go beyond
some of these
heuristics so what is it further do we
want to know so the first thing we want
to know is really what are these units
of communication
the second is what are the rules that
operate over these units to produce
different
let's say sentences for now but uh let's
see what
they really are maybe we don't really
know what they really are
and the third thing is to see if there
are long-range dependencies over the
historic context of the sound
and finally can we learn the meanings of
the their vocalizations
so what have we seen so far there are
two main points that i'll
like to take away from the slides before
one is data collection and annotation is
expensive
and two how do we generalize beyond
heuristics so the rest of the talk is
about what we are trying to do and some
of our first steps
and the first thing that we want to do
is automatically annotate
the data that is not annotated the
second thing we want to do is
use these annotations that we obtain
over the
audio data to then find these symbols
and rules that
govern the behavior of these
vocalizations and how sperm wheels
communicate
so first talking about automatic
annotation so what you really want to do
is two things with an automatic
annotation
given this kind of audio data where we
have vocalizations from
four different ways uh we see we
all you hear is a continuous stream of
uh audio right we don't know who that
belongs to or where these
clicks really lie so there's two parts
to this
one we want to be able to separate out
the different clicks
uh and attribute and find out their
positions and two we want to be able to
attribute them to the different ways
so first the first part is identifying
where these clicks are
so like you can see on the left is the
waveform and on the right is the
spectrogram
in the left side you can see there are
some really soft clicks
that can be seen more clearly in the
spectrogram and the thing is that we do
not want to
lose out on these soft clicks because
they could actually be responses
of one with the other wheel responding
back to the previous wheel and they're
very precious
and here is some images of noise and we
can see here how some of the noise can
end up looking very similar to
some of the clicks because this is noise
from the microphone and disturbances
sometimes are very clicky
so uh we also want to
have a very we do not want to detect
these as clicks
so we model the problem of click
detection as a regression problem
where we look at we take a signal and
what you see here is the green window is
the part of the signal we take
and the black window is the window over
which we make a decision
so in the black window the job of our
clip detector
is to tell us where does the peak lie
and by modeling this problem in this way
we also generate a lot of hard negatives
for example if the wave moves to the
left or to the right
the peak is also going to move within
maybe the black window also go out of
the green window
where there would be cases of both the
click is just outside the black window
or there is no click
in the green black there's no peak in
the black window
and uses oh this is our model that we
use to model
this as a regression problem and the
output is the location of the peak in
the black window
and here we look at some of our results
and uh
while it may not be super clear i'm not
sure but uh
we can see that there are uh those the
clicks marked in red
are some of the clicks which were not
originally annotated
so not only does this help us recover
clicks that are very close by
and maybe annotations have been missed
for but also
uh uh can detect very soft clicks with
greater than 96 percent accuracy which
the other model was unable to do
and here's a look at some more the
second thing was about click separation
so here what you're trying to do is
really take two clicks and
uh use those two clicks to ask the
question of whether
it's the same speaker yes or no
and the idea is to recursively use this
question to pass the rest of the
to pass the data set and split them
across the different
individuals so when uh originally ipi
is an information that's used to
identify and attribute clicks
to different speakers but if we were to
just use ipa information and angle of
arrival information
we could do it to an accuracy of about
60 and
that's uh one reason is because ipa
estimation for softer clicks
such as the one shown below can be
really noisy because the pulse the peaks
of the pulses are not very clearly
defined but if you use the raw waveform
the this the separation accuracy goes up
but to almost 70 percent
and then uh another thing we were
thinking of is whether
asking this question is too hard and
maybe just separating out
the mains the tagged whale from the rest
of the whale is enough
of a question to ask for our experiments
and for that we get a much uh
we can do that much better so we're
we're we're still
uh iterating over different versions of
this model
and um oh yeah
it'll hopefully get better so the next
thing uh
that i'm going to talk about is the
second part of the talk which is
identifying the underlying symbols and
roots
so one question that you know now that
we have a system in place to
automatically annotate the data
you know what we want to really do in
the second part is maybe
find a way to really break down this
problem and identify patterns that
repeat
by making as little assumptions as
possible
and find out the smallest unit that
describes the data the best
so let's say these are clicks uh we see
here
and um and they occur in time so
we could probably uh according to how
they previously
uh visualize it's uh either by dashes or
by dots
and they're spread over time but another
way of looking at this is that
we could use the structure that is found
out by all the
amazing work that's been done in the
community so there are these codas
and if you look at these coders and
instead of placing them next to each
other what if we place them like this
so it looks like a dialogue between
like not a dialogue but three sentences
maybe said by a whale
and while what i do next will not really
make sense immediately hopefully it will
make sense in the next slide what we do
next is connect the
eighth click of the jth coda with the
eighth click of the j
plus one encoder so what we're doing is
we're trying to draw lines to see how
much these
vary because traditionally a oneplus one
plus three coder can vary a little bit
but how do you decide where to draw the
line and if this variation is even
meaningful
right so what we've done is we went from
an audio form to
like using existing knowledge about
these coders to this
representation and now if you look at
the entire audio file
and we plot out these representations
we see something like this here there's
a green where and a red wave
and we see that the red wave is still
making a one plus one plus three coder
but it's wearing it very little by
little and then it's increasing and then
decreasing and increasing and decreasing
and the green whale also seems to follow
and if
all this was really noise this small
variation then we would not see any of
this following behavior
so then why does the red will really
follow the green wave
so so i think this was a very important
find like to us
we it was very important that we we
found out that maybe we should be more
careful about the kind of
representations we decide to
or the assumptions we try to make we
also made a book of ways
with all the audio data that shane's
data set had
and these are just some more
visualizations just to have a look
it was really fun like uh dude it
actually really helped us understand
some of these behaviors a little better
like
we we could see some uh red whale
following blue whale and we could also
try to indirectly see okay maybe this
whale is talking to this whale and this
one is talking to the other
there were also like other patterns that
like emerged by visualizing it in this
way
like oh it's it's known that just before
dives fails make very short
and flat short coders and then we see
like these
short coders and even when they make
long coders just before they dive
they still have these very flat patterns
as compared to the
much varying patterns that they make
when they come back or when they come
back from the dice or when they're on
the surface
and besides this we also have some
metadata and what we
uh really want to do next is be able to
tie up some of this metadata
with the audio data we have to
understand
to like in some sense contextualize
this audio using the metadata so here we
see uh
depth data along with the metadata it's
depth in meters
and um like while here doesn't uh uh
there's two things we want to see one is
local behavior
of when it's saying making a sound how
does its local behavior vary
and in below you see a larger window
where you you can make sense of what was
it going to do right after
like here it said something and then it
went on a dive so what what we really
want to do is be able to
uh understand where it makes what
behavior using both the local and the
global context
okay so the next thing uh that we want
to look at is the
there's also additional metadata that i
mentioned uh initially
so this is a book by a data and
visualization research lab on the left
side they have this really beautiful
visualization but what we're trying to
do is try to make something similar for
our project too
where we have this uh visualization on
the right side
of the sperm build or diving in multiple
dives
and we're still working on this and this
is just the first version but
what we do see here is these uh little
finger like patterns on the bottom of
the dive is when
they go they dive deep and then they'd
go deeper to maybe like
find food and come back and then they do
that repeatedly
and while they do not really have
communication clicks around that area
we still are interested in knowing if
those behaviors die back to something
they discuss when they come back to
their surface
so another thing is what are the
differences between the codas
so oh or what what what how what's the
distribution of the different coders
so most coders are five clear coders in
the dataset that we have
and uh it's like roughly out of three
thousand nine hundred
about three thousand of them are five
coders and the rest there
there's a lesser distribution across the
rest and um
if now another thing to do is if you
were to make the same visualization
of the four click five click and uh six
click coders but assemble them in
ascending order of their length
we see these patterns on the right so
while you can see a very flat pattern
so let's look at the uh graph in the
middle while you can see a very flat
pattern like on the left side
on the right side there's more of a
continuum so how do we decide where
should we draw the line like what part
is this
some kind of a continuous communication
or like how do we decide where we should
draw the line to find out the smallest
units
that they used to communicate and
just adding color to the previous plot
if we uh
color code them according to where in
the dive all these clicks or quotas are
happening
we notice that the this it
this clear distinction between between
what they say just before they dive
and what they see on the surface and
what they say when they return
so like the uh it's not very clear from
maybe this plot but towards
the longer coders are what they make
usually when they ascend
mostly but there's also like some blue
distributed in the middle but
clearly the shorter coders are the ones
that they make just before they dive
and there's not much of use of that
later
okay just coming back to this question
of is when the click starts
all that there is to a click or is there
more so another thing we do is
with with the same plots we scale up the
radius of the circle depending on the
power of the click
so we also see these other interesting
patterns of there is
definitely variation and it's it's
constant wait like
so this variation is it is it
intentional or not
it's something we're looking at now
next is there could also be other voice
queues so if on the left side is a plot
where we take
clicks across different waves and just
superimpose them on top of each other
and it looks really messy but on the
right side we take
clicks from the same veil and
superimpose them onto each other
and it turns out that there seems to be
a lot of
similarity between clicks made from the
same wave and there seems to be these
oh so on the right of that is the
fourier transform and there seems to be
these
uh distinct peaks at two
different frequencies
and if we take the two principal
components of these uh
waveforms and do clustering and then we
recolor the
original plots based on the cluster they
belong to we also
notice that there seems to be a
variation between when they use what
kind of a frequency
so it could also be something that could
be important that we should factor in
when we do any of our future analysis
and this is just a quick video which
looks at a
new map plot of our of the different
clusters
in the data set so the lime green
colored plots are the five click coders
you can see
as we walk across them we can go from
the longer one plus one plus three
coders to the shorter one plus one plus
three coders
and also the continuous five r coders
and so on
and in the interest of time i'll just
move to the next slide
okay so now finally the question you
want to
with the question we started out with so
what is the smallest number of discrete
units that explain the data distribution
the best
so how should we represent the
vocalizations
we want to be able to attribute them to
what we have what is the coda at what
depth
how loud what direction was the probably
facing and at what time
and another question that we want to ask
is should we be thinking of something
more continuous
like a more continuous representation or
should we try to find out the smallest
units that still govern uh like
transitions over which cover and how
um the different quotas are produced
and oh i'm sorry just to mention one
more thing is like when we go from the
representation on the top which is
continuous like music to discrete like
language
we will be uh missing out on some
information but what we want to do is
miss out on the information that
does not determine that's that is not
really information but
it's just a factor of variation for
example when we go from
audio or sounds that we make each one of
us can say things very differently but
when we go down to the written form we
try to uh maintain as much information
as possible so we want to make this
transition as less
lossy yes and
this is a slide which is talking about
the same thing so it is about like if we
were to use base form it's the richest
form of representation that we can
really get
and the right side is some binarization
of this
but what we want to really do is as we
go to a lower dimensional representation
which might be easier for us to handle
but we want to not lose out much
information
so what we do is uh something similar to
what
shane was also talking about is we
hierarchically cluster
those different coder types into these
grouplets
but now the question is where in this
hierarchy should we really draw a line
and say this is the number of clusters
we should have
or this is the number of words we should
have and for that
you we will talk about that in two
slides
because we tie up that decision with the
process of
making the next prediction because if
you think about it
like how do we decide what are the right
words it it is also in some way tied up
with the decision of
how does this decision help us produce
more meaningful sentences
or what does that represent what's the
smallest number of words which would
help us predict
uh uh the next sentence better
and like if you look at variability
within the cluster
it's not uh it's it's not that much
it's uh it's fairly uniform within
within clusters
the first parsely uh numbered clusters
of variability can be a little more
so the next thing that uh is talking
about is can we build a model that can
predict the vocalization
so here what we do is the yellow box
is the input the left box is the context
and the red box is the output so what we
do is given an input under context we
want to predict what are the next
sentences
that the wheel is going to say
okay and uh what we do here on the right
side is our language model which is
a probability distribution over the
entire sentences or text
and what we have on the right here this
theta
is the uh this is a seek to seek style
language model where
it encodes the context and tries to
predict
the output just go that t plus one t
plus two t plus three and t
plus four okay and this is uh the
evaluation metric we will use for uh to
describe in the rest of the graph
and in natural language processing or
this so this is called perplexity and in
natural language processing there's a
way of evaluating language models
and um so the best language model would
be one that can predict an unseen death
set
right so what we really want or uh to do
is minimize the perplexity so we
maximize
the probability of making the best
predictions
okay so here are some results on the
left side we see
the effective context on making a
prediction so we see
a drop in perplexity as we go from
context size one two three four five
and in a in a random baseline like we
just take no context
the perplexity is much higher like
almost closer to twenty something
so i didn't make put it on in the plot
but oh yes
and on the right side we look at the
effective model complexity
where there's uh we compare it against
an n-gram model
and we take an rnn model an attention
model and it see it
seems like we benefit from using odd
ordering and uh
and there there seems to be relations
over longer ranges
that uh help make better predictions of
what the next
next quarter should be okay so
one thing that i left off at previously
was how do we decide the right number of
clusters
so the decision of making a prediction
of what the next word should be becomes
harder the larger number of words
and like for example if we only had one
word in our cluster
the model could just predict that one
word repeatedly and it would just have
very low perplexity right but what we
really want to do is
make the problem harder like by try
increase the vocabulary size but at the
same time
be fair in our comparison of models
across different vocabulary sizes
so what we want so to do this we need to
turn the models distribution of a higher
level back into a distribution over the
lower level
to make all of our perplexities
comparable and
i can get into the details but uh
like if anybody is interested and
uh the next thing is the effect of the
size of the training data
so as we increase the amount of training
data we see that the prediction error in
the next quarter goes down
so right now we're in a very low data
regime and it's
it is it is in it's expected that this
behavior is expected
but what we hope to do is using our
automatic annotation as we talked about
earlier and
the models that we're looking at
together to
increase the amount of data and increase
the power of our models which will then
change uh increase expressivity of our
models which will then change to this
curve
completely and then try to build the
best model that can probably capture
uh the distribution over the next the
best language model that we can
okay and here is some is a qualitative
evaluation of the predictions of the
model
on the top is the ground truth and on
the bottom is the prediction
in green is the context and red on the
top is
ground truth and red on the bottom is
predictions and the numbers there
are the probability that the model
thinks that this will be the next
quarter
and um so what is simplest for the model
like in a lot of the data we see that
the next
coder is almost is roughly the same as
the previous coder
so for a simple language model all it
can do is just keep
uh outputting the same code repeatedly
but that's not one we are interested in
right so what we want to do is be able
to
model for these variations which is what
our language model has
been able to capture to some extent and
oh
here are some more examples and um
while sometimes uh like in the first
example we see
that it predicted the ground truth was
0.52 but we don't directly just use the
max the the cluster corresponding to the
maximum probability we try to use uh we
sample from our output distribution so
we get a longer quota there but it also
still
across these predictions has a higher
confidence on even the ground truth
maybe uh and the probability otherwise
for the other one would be 1 and 30
uh which is our trusted size and these
are some longer generated whale
conversations
which seem to capture some variation
across the different codas
and uh this is just the conclusion slide
so
what have we found out so far so one
thing is that our visualizations have
helped us find patterns of variation
within the vocalization
imitation behaviors of imitation of
following rhythms and of where how
sometimes waves interrupt each other
which were sometimes earlier treated as
repetitions
of roughly the same quota by an
individual so the second thing is with
increasing amount of history as context
for prediction the ability of models to
predict the next code also improves
and this is some evidence of non-workout
markovian behavior in the vocalization
and finally we can generate uh good or
highly probable responses
to sounds by firmwaves which should help
us conduct interventional studies
in a more informed way but yes these
models will continue
hopefully continue to improve as we get
more and more data via both data
collection and automatic annotation
and the next steps really oh yeah this
is just
a fun slide but the next steps really is
to conduct
some of these interventional studies and
actually go back and
replay some of the predictions back to
the waves and see if they respond in
phase and this will also tell us where
we should draw the line
and probably will uh
overthrow some of the assumptions that
we've made along the way
but uh yes i think this would be a way
we can decide where we should draw the
line across the different
uh where we should draw the line when we
decide what's the most discrete unit
and that's all thank you
uh thank you real really great talk um
patricia and shane